este es de acercamiento en el que está
inglaterra desde los primeros días de
enero de 2021 empezará a ser levantado
paulatinamente para evitar que nuevos
los down nuevos confinamientos sean
necesarios en este país así lo ha
explicado el primer ministro boris
johnson quien reveló esta tarde en el
parlamento su hoja de ruta entre marzo y
junio de este año para recuperar lo que
ha dicho la libertad de la población son
cuatro etapas iniciando en marzo les he
comentado que se priorizará entonces la
educación el regreso de los niños a las
aulas personalmente cara a cara y
también se permitirá que se empiecen a
reunir las personas fuera de las casas
en esta ocasión apenas dos casas esto
será el 29 de marzo en abril
entonces los comercios no esenciales las
peluquerías los gimnasios podrán
regresar y también se permitirá el
servicio en restaurantes que tengan
jardín
en mayo se espera entonces que se
permitan las reuniones dentro de casas y
para no antes del 21 de junio se espera
que se acaben las restricciones ha dicho
el primer ministro que espera que para
julio finales de julio de este año la
gran mayoría de la población adulta haya
recibido por lo menos la primera dosis
de la vacuna pero ha dejado claro en
première en que el país debe ser humilde
y debe estar atento de lo que sucede con
el virus tanto aquí nacionalmente como a
nivel internacional ante el temor de que
aparezcan nuevas variantes de este cómic